the thing about war is it only works as
both sides believe they're the good guys
the truth is we're not so different we
fight to get back what was once our
but in the end all and this is the end
it's just a city you'll get used to
watching them fall thank recite for us
we need to figure out our next vote hell
no next move and there is no we
what is that we're not here to eat those
ports not on a shrimp oh this guy's got
pork god you're weird I'm not looking
for super prints i doesn't matter can't
fight these people
not even with whatever it is your hand
can do it's cheap it's not they're
holding off friends or family and I'm
not going to stop there
[Music]
more death is coming the only thing
keepin Manhattan for Kremlin to a pile
of dust the four of you the wars are New
York it's over
not yet
[Music]
I fear their horns
I can see you formed a kind of bond
by promising with temporary
they will disappoint you Jessica
like it or not
you belong out there together
glad we found each other I'm not hugging
you spent a long week
you